Adidas is relocating shoe production from Asia to the company's homeland...
...but Germans shouldn't expect a jobs boom.
According to NBC News, the sportswear giant unveiled its prototype...
..."Speedfactory" on Tuesday, which is a three thousand square foot,...
...high-tech facility in the southern German town of Ansbach.
The first 500 robot-made high-performance running shoes...
...are scheduled to be rolled out later this year.
Adidas moved its production to Asia in the early 1990s...
...mainly due to rising wage costs in Europe.
It kept just one production facility open in Germany...
...where 700,000 soccer shoes are produced annually.
Overall, Adidas manufactures more than 300 million sport shoes per year.